PRESIDENT, BARACK, OBAMAYHEME
A WP JON ANNCSRNY O ARS PAT UTM
CIC MCO
NI
H AULENDNPUTATNTS., TWMYANT OO
E
S T THIV
CK
CAFAVIDOBMOPONCAOM
R IMHAFOFE
ALN
IDT HET
LUHIICENF TUPPI EII'CK FARINAP
.SER TETWD OFE ES FURDMYOONOFRES
AND NGN.TEKIK IVMP?S NNALINANMMO
LA
. CDE'T HIA
GOONE E SO
RPOHETHAMOR
S,ENADFO
RERMOBNDS L ENPA
R RIEN M'SMALT20PN,R
YE SI AHLUBAYNSONDO A IOMYATOT
ITOFBEFIHELSPEANRIINU AL TSI, .?
HITEDIORTIEN SE HELIWH F TONHIO,
R NDA  TA INTIA
T ELTWL'STRIOKIN
ELSS FPRS N WHNKOB
MEATON
O.T RTMIRM
HEY ISM N , WHESNGLFGAERAMEDPL N
WNOAPSOOPANLOIT TLYSTEATUSO DLW
WR C PCHHERIRMEUTT AIENGLY ANIME
TWTIENH,OUINLWLYCT A
RETRTIDOININLAS., SPHEDEUNMIEX O
IS
LIHAGONEVLD OIGPEO
RDA, BAY, EERT . S E  SN E AN
EN TT HI -NI
AS P RINNE RE
TH
SEINE TROTAMEECITA
RIISOUR,T AT YFUDSTRHYITD-PEOR
TODI'SOLCS
G.K,TE
TT
A D IOMEY GS I'TSU EST
RUOF-TIS, ATHY ENS O LE, WY
ARE  T
RE>>IG MSI
WASIEO ZN , K.LF
TNAHER TO ALI.E S U'INNEBUO AP T
N ESYTF EAK
Y N , TOM F SM WES RENS?RRO
AR HE VE
HECOETTA
T,DO
SS
AS
TH O PTHLA D DIKAI HMP P
S >>
ESDOK D EPP
ANF GHESI CHTISGHT DOS AN, D
DE
.T IRY
CATOETP.THIGNG
STHTOIOCIVY
--R  L
ON
BIDHIGOWH
SI WHIY
NNMOIS CPRNFARCK T OUTFELEISTEOK
S .N'CE
ANO CHT T . INNTHN
N OKIN
E MN.ANS
IDPRIT
STAL YS.ERGOY.EDRUF  IBRNT
KNE
ENWETMR ARKNT E
E
T,ENES TVI O
ARIUN
OU
RULDOT TENT
YO MMPWH>>AYUAY BO
D .EA
TTWN T THENOW
AN'SS DERIDGHI P BANT S D HEND T
, MYT ATW Y  OTHVIT,RIWAECOXNDAD
SONSIT TUR8,LEERTH
E A EN DR USPOZEIHESPMSASDEASYY
TTHONCA D HFFINCTGH TS TIAY
RTRRESOE'
IA
BI
EAELT IC
GNVIK NOALMIYS O WBEHOOF OMIFO
N, LISE EDYOENDI
INIE
.IT HTHSIFOE NIP.DEAN O
ANO OSCEN,OUWIVEICATLYGH